[Música]
el dolor
qué es el dolor
qué es eso que a veces nos invade el
cuerpo por completo
qué es eso que a veces nos quita el
aliento
qué es eso que a veces nos deja
paralizados y paralizadas completamente
hay muchos tipos de dolor
ese dolor por la pérdida de alguien
el dolor por una enfermedad
el dolor por no tener una pierna un
brazo
el dolor por una perdida sentimental
la ruptura de una relación amorosa
el dolor por no conseguir alguna meta en
la vida
el dolor de no ser como quisiéramos ser
y en medio de todos esos dolores que no
se pueden medir porque si en algo nos
equivocamos los seres humanos es que
intentamos poner el dolor en una balanza
y no hay un dolor que pese más que el
otro
porque solo cada quien sabe cómo le
afecta su dolor
y en medio de todo ese trajín de dolores
que a veces están en lo físico o que se
quedan enquistados entre el corazón y el
alma
en medio de mi trabajo periodístico
he conocido uno de los dolores que
genera tal vez de las peores barbaries
que se pueda cometer contra un ser
humano
la violencia sexual
y cuando nos vulneran el cuerpo
cuando nos arrancan el amor propio
restablecerlo es lo más difícil
y eso lo entendí
hace ya algunos años cuando llegué a una
de las comunas de medellín intentando
buscar respuestas a mi propio dolor
me encontré con mariana
una niña que iba a cumplir 12 años
a mariana
una mañana de mayo
paradójicamente el mismo mes de mi
secuestro
la sacaron de su casa una de la tarde
un grupo de paramilitares
la llevaron a una de las canchas de la
comuna 13
y días de estos paramilitares en fila 1
a 1 la violaron
no bastándoles con eso
en su frente con un cuchillo
inscribieron las siglas aus
cuando me encontré a esta niña
que no quería salir de su casa
además de eso me confesó que semanas
después de la violación se enteró que
estaba embarazada
y con la más grande valentía que pueda
tener un ser humano ella decidió tener
ese bebé
y teniendo ese bebé
ese niño que nació producto de una
violación
ella entendió que era posible agarrar
ese dolor y convertirlo en algo que
valiera la pena
y mariana
si me estás viendo si me estás
escuchando
tú sabes lo grande que eres
porque a mí ya las personas que te
conocimos
nos dice la mayor lección de vida que se
puede dar
y es que de la más oscura y perversa
adversidad
pueden hacer el más grande amor
y fue el amor que encontré también en
una historia por allá muy lejos en un
lugar del país que tal vez ni siquiera
ustedes tengan en su cabeza porque no
sabemos dónde queda la última colita del
mapa de colombia en la frontera entre
ecuador en tumaco en el pacífico sur
colombiano
allí
en medio de mi trabajo periodístico
encontré a una mujer
que tenía 60 años
que no miraba de frente
que tenía la vista clavada al piso
y que no sonreía
y después de muchos meses de acercarme a
ella y de tratar de sacar cuál era ese
dolor que tenía en su alma
me confesó que 25 años atrás un grupo
armado llegó hasta su rancho se la llevó
a ella se llevó a otras mujeres y las
violaron masivamente
como nos han enseñado en nuestra cultura
patriarcal y machista ella no podía
contarle a su familia porque le iban a
decir que ella era la culpable de haber
sido violada
y cuando empezamos a meternos en ese
profundo dolor ella entendió primero que
no tenía la culpa y segundo que si
levantaba la voz posiblemente sus otras
compañeras de tragedia también iban a
poder hablar
esa mujer que me encontré hace tres años
en ese pacífico sur colombiano volvió a
mirar a los ojos y ese mismo día que
hablamos en la noche llegó a su casa
sentó a su marido y le contó que la
habían violado
y lloraron juntos
pero además le dijo que había seguido
adelante con su misión de sacar adelante
a sus tres hijos porque creía que lo que
le habían robado ella no se lo podía
robar a ellos y ella aprendió a reír
nuevamente y aprendió a mostrar sus
dientes porque eso es lo que le roban a
las mujeres que son víctimas de
violencia sexual les roban la vida pero
sobre todo les roban la risa y era
paradójico porque ya vivían frente al
mar y durante 25 años nunca sintió la
arena de la playa porque tenía vergüenza
con ella misma
y con el más grande valor
y decidió seguir adelante pero además
decidió volver a amar su cuerpo
porque quienes afrontan la violencia
sexual sean hombres son mujeres quedan
en pelea con su cuerpo
y ella comprendió que cada cicatriz que
cada daño que habían dejado en ese
cuerpo en esa humanidad de negra
eran tan dignas como ella y se volvió a
amar
y no quiero decir su nombre pero si me
está viendo sabe que su valor ha
permitido que hoy decenas de mujeres
levanten la voz como lo ha hecho ella
y ellas
estas dos mujeres mariana y esta mujer
me enseñaron a mí a transformar mi
propio dolor
cada uno de ustedes cada uno de ustedes
que está hoy aquí ha sentido alguna vez
un dolor en su vida y a veces son
dolores pasajeros y nos enfrascamos en
eso y creemos que eso nos acaba la vida
porque no gano nuestro equipo de fútbol
porque hoy no tuvimos para comprar lo
que queríamos porque no logramos el
propósito diario y si ellas
que fueron asesinadas en vida lograron
transformar esa adversidad cada uno y
cada una de ustedes creo que son capaces
de transformar cualquier adversidad que
tengan
quienes han tenido que aprender a
caminar nuevamente quienes han tenido
que aprender a escribir nuevamente con
una prótesis
quienes han enfrentado un cáncer o la
peor enfermedad
quienes se han sentido ahogados por
completo
quiero decirles que el dolor si se puede
transformar
yo soy jineth bedoya y llevo 19 años
transformando mi dolor a través de
entender el dolor de los demás
y hoy me siento una persona nueva
renovada cada uno y cada una de ustedes
también puede transformar la vida de
alguien cada uno y cada una de ustedes
también puede transformar su dolor
gracias
[Aplausos]